we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to David P there's this guy Eric
from Mass who has been
um calling in with all sorts of coveted
conspiracy theories since the start of
the pandemic I told you last week that
Donald Trump has been asking around
about ways that he might be able to
imprison journalists adversarial to him
if he were to become the president of
the United States again
and I think imprisoning journalists for
their opinions is bad uh Eric from Mass
says I should be imprisoned for the
things I said about covid listen to this
hey David sir from us I just watched the
thing I put about Trump and the
journalists I was like you might be
shooting Advanced
um after all the lives and stuff with
Colvin and all the people you got hurt
with vaccines you know they were live
but you don't want accountability for
what you did lying to people scaring
people you know Eric still seems to
struggle with the understanding that I
don't create any views or make
assertions myself about vaccines or
covet
I I I'm a commentator
I bring to you
the best synthesis that I've done of the
Medical Science and Eric continues to
talk to me as if I'm coming up with the
information about how vaccines work or
anything about covet it's very strange
all over a common cold
make people wear masks make kids wear
masks disgusting yeah I mean I didn't do
anything I didn't make anyone do
anything absolutely disgusting what you
did and promoted and you must be
[ __ ] your pants thinking that
accountability is coming and that's one
thing with you Democrats you never
ever
from pregnancy
to anything else take accountability for
your own actions but you get it you got
people killed you got people hurt okay
by the way
Democrats don't take accountability for
pregnancy
have you heard of Herschel Walker so
Eric from Mass still struggling with
thinking and Common Sense
I predict I will not be imprisoned for
my reporting on vaccines maybe there's a
place that will take your bet on that I
would not bet on me being imprisoned for
covet coverage we have a fantastic bonus
show for you today oh the bonus show
where you want to make money everybody
else that makes money to fund themselves
is bad we are going to go through all of
the scenarios in the House of
Representatives that could lead to
Republican control
or that could lead to democratic control
not a conversation I expected to be
having with you today that's for sure
we're also going to talk about new
polling which went to student loan uh
borrowers and said if you had student
loan forgiveness or for those who were
getting it what do you plan to use the
money for and the answers were very
interesting and a lot of people
misunderstand the answers a lot of
people I don't know if deliberately or
not
seem to be thinking oh see their answers
to what they're going to spend the money
on proves it wasn't a good idea to do
the Forgiveness very much the opposite
we will talk about that and number three
Dave Chappelle hosted Saturday Night
Live over the weekend and one of the
things he did during his monologue was
he criticized Kanye West he criticized
Kyrie Irving for their anti-semitic
statements but in so doing
Dave Chappelle reinforced some of those
very same anti-semitic tropes very
disappointing to see the right loved it
the right now they see Dave Chappelle as
their hero but um it was pretty bad so
we're going to talk about that on
today's bonus show as well sign up at
join
Pacman
.com join pacman.com
you can use the coupon code 24 starts
now I believe 24 starts tomorrow with
Donald Trump's announcement although now
there are rumors it might only be
remarks it might not be an announcement
well we will figure it out very quickly
uh joinpakman.com coupon code 24 starts
now we will see you on the bonus show or
otherwise back here tomorrow